- Well physically I could, but
emotionally and spiritually
I can't eat at the same place again.
- Let's try someplace new then.
- Well, your idea of someplace
new scares me a little bit.
- You guys ordering lunch?
- Yeah, you know, we were
just thinking about it.
- You want in, or?
- Yes, I'm starving!
Just order me something from
wherever you guys are going.
You know me, I'm super low-maintenance.
(bearded man chuckles)
(whimsical music)
- So I'm high-maintenance because
I like things done a certain way?
(in unison) - Absolutely.
- My name is Bennett; I ain't even in it.
- Okay, I don't even
know what you're doing.
- My name is Paul... It's between ya'all.
- So you're saying this,
is low maintenance?
- Well...
- This is what I should aspire to?
- This is a far more nuanced conversation
than we should be having.
- But not too nuanced, right?!
Too nuanced and I might be
labeled "high-maintenance."
- Look, do you want to
order lunch with us or not?
- Yes!
- And from where should we order
this super low-maintenance lunch?
- Wherever.
- Wherever?
- My name is Guinevere, and
I'd gladly choose anywhere.
(singsongy) You choose!
- Fine.
- How about here?
The menu smells weird.
- You know what?
I am not hungry, so... okay.
- It does smell super weird.
- You look like a methhead accountant.
- I'm into it.
- You know I can't get my
grandfather's inheritance
unless I have this beard
for three months, okay?
(outro music)